you've probably all heard about medical
racism where people of color get worse
health care because of their race and
that's usually due to human bias so it's
important that doctors rely less on
their feelings and more on the numbers
except did you know that numbers can be
racist too i'll tell you more in a
segment called how did we get here
tonight we're going to talk about
medicine and just a little tip laughter
is not the best one if you don't believe
me find someone with a peanut allergy
give them a rhesus cup and then tell
them a knock knock joke
knock knock they're dead now
specifically we're going to talk about a
practice in medicine called race
correction that's when medical
calculations are adjusted based on a
patient's race and race correction can
result in disastrous outcomes for people
of color now these adjustments affect
just about every part of the body but
since we're still in a giant respiratory
pandemic let's start by talking about
the lungs i think of them as the tia and
tamara of the human body because there
are two of them and they are very close
to my heart
for more than a century doctors have
assumed that black people have a smaller
lung capacity than white people why well
to understand we're going to have to go
all the way back to 1851 to meet a man
named samuel cartwright now i'm going to
warn you you're going to be really mad
at this guy but you can never hate him
as much as his own barber obviously did
now cartwright was a white doctor who
decided he was going to investigate
quote the diseases and physical
peculiarities of the negro race which is
already a red flag right there
it's like when you go on a first date
and the guy tells you all his exes are
crazy
chad
the only thing all those girls have in
common is you
now lo and behold dr cartwright
discovered a bunch of what he called
negro diseases for example he insisted
he found one called drapedomania that
was rampant in the black population he
said that this horrifying disease and i
swear i'm not making it up induces the
negro to run away from service that's
right this white man thought that
enslaved people were running away
because of a medical disease and not and
i'm just spitballing here because
they're enslaved
that's basically like saying i've
discovered a disease that makes a
waitress spit in my food every time i
grab her ass i call it diner mania
also
cartwright discovered another disease
that i'm not even going to try to
pronounce because he made it up so why
should i bother
cartwright claimed that this disease
made enslaved people
lazy
that's right the enslaved people were
lazy not the white people enjoying a
mint julep while they did all the work
and the main symptom of this disease
lesions on the enslaved people's backs
now i wonder how they got there and this
will probably come as no surprise
cartwright said the best treatment for
his made-up disease was more
whipping
that's the worst medical prescription
since well laughter so what does all of
this have to do with the lung capacity
we were talking about earlier okay well
on top of everything else cartwright was
also the first doctor to measure um lung
capacity between black and white people
he called something he used something
called a spirometer which looks like a
very scientific bond
and he concluded that black people have
a lower lung capacity than white people
now my instinct would be not to believe
anything this reverse eddie munster said
but the medical profession went a
different way because to this day
spirometers use a race-based correction
that assumes that a
10 to 15 percent smaller lung capacity
for black patients but the actual
science on that is very unclear race is
connected to things like access to
health care or likelihood of living in
polluted areas things that people of
color are more likely to experience so
while there's no evidence that race
determines lung health there is plenty
of evidence that racism could and those
are the kinds of things an algorithm
does not pick up besides anyone who
wants to say that black people have weak
lungs should be required to listen to
whitney houston do this
[Applause]
she tricked us into loving america yeah
that woman has the lung capacity of 1
000 women and one hot air balloon now
why does all this talk of lung capacity
matter well because if you think someone
has diminished lung capacity then you're
not as worried when they get a
respiratory infection and their numbers
are lower you might take longer to get
the medical care which could lead to
more serious illness and all those small
decisions add up for example according
to the cdc black people are currently
hospitalized for covid at a rate two and
a half times that of white people so the
numbers matter and it's not just the
lungs that are affected by these
algorithms because the racism creeps
through all the rest of the body as well
for example black women have the highest
rates of c-section at least partially
because of something called a v-back
score the v-back score is an algorithm
that estimates the chance a woman has of
a successful vaginal birth after she's
had a c-section think of it like an
s-a-t for your vag
the v-back score is important because
c-sections are much riskier than vaginal
births and up until just a couple months
ago the v-back actually automatically
said that black and latinx women had a
higher risk score than white women that
means more women of color were advised
to get a c-section which can be
dangerous but recently researchers
looked into why that was included in the
algorithm at all and like marjorie
taylor green says to herself every
morning when she looks in the mirror get
ready for some racism
because
they realize the algorithm was based on
an old study that found that being
unmarried and not having insurance
actually increased the risk it wasn't
race at all but someone saw a single
parent and lack of health care access
and program that into their little
algorithm as black and latinx which is
so devastatingly racist i'd like to find
whoever wrote it and give them this
haircut
but
guess what it gets worse because the
american heart association has something
called a heart failure risk score that's
the score doctors use to predict the
risk of death in patients who have been
admitted to the hospital the higher the
score the greater your risk it's a
single number that can change your life
think of it like the powerball except
the prize is getting admitted to the
hospital
according to the new england journal of
medicine the heart failure risk score
automatically assigns three additional
points to any patient identified as
non-black
so basically think of those points like
jokes on an episode of prairie home
companion you're gonna get a whole lot
more of them if you're white
now what this means for parents is that
the algorithm automatically categorizes
all black patients as lower risk whether
they are or not and that has dangerous
results a 2019 study found that black
and latinx patients with heart failure
were less likely than white patients to
be admitted to the cardiology service
that's heartbreaking literally and the
list goes on a race-adjusted algorithm
makes black americans kidney function
look better even though they have higher
rates of end-stage kidney disease a
different algorithm used by hospitals to
decide which patients get follow-up care
let healthier white patients into the
programs ahead of black patients who
were sicker and the examples are endless
but my point is hospitals treat people
not numbers patients of color deserve to
go to the doctor and receive health care
without bias and for doctors to take
into account their individual
circumstances instead of their race
but until then every single person who
makes one of these racist algorithms
should have to get the cart right this
has been how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you